hello reject nation it's Greg Alva here
I'm John here so last night was the
golden globes of 2018 I normally could
care less about the Golden Globes all
about us and all about Oscars - I could
care less about it but Rosa Parra over
on patreon she specifically requested
that we cover this so Rosa thank you for
requesting this and thank you to
everyone at patreon right now we were
almost at a hundred patrons and it's
growing really fast we have over three
hundred posts on there majority of them
being exclusive videos so thank you guys
thank you to all the patronage X and
love to have you guys join us too got a
lot of exclusive reactions in Q&A video
so let's check out this Golden Globes
recap the only winner I heard about was
James Franco I actually haven't checked
the internet or anything to find out who
won what or what won Best Picture who
else won I'm about to find out right now
um who won anything we could talk about
it whoo I could watch call me by your
name last night and that's what I did
instead of watching the Golden Globes I
don't think this one I don't know movie
want any awards but I thought it was
important to watch the Golden Globes
just kicks off the 2018 award show
season another incredible year Sam
Rockwell fair in the Intellivision
categories there was more than one happy
surprise throughout the night big little
lies was definitely the front-runner
sweet the awards with Nicole
nice okay nice rightfully so she also
made sure to take time to praise the
brave women of the hashtag yes you were
so brave and hopefully shows like this
more will be made so people out there
who are feeling silenced by harassment
discrimination abuse time is up
we see you we hear you and we will tell
your stories Elizabeth moth won Best
Actress in a Drama performance by
leading actor good for you even stardom
not one but two characters in the hit
series Fargo good for a monumental night
for Sterling Kay brown and this is us as
he took home Best Performance by an
actor and a TV drama making him the
first black actor to win a Golden Globe
in that category
really
and so what I appreciate so much about
this thing is that I haven't been seen
for who I am and being appreciated for
who I am and it makes it that much more
difficult to dismiss me or dismiss
anybody who looks like me as far as the
comedy hey
and the cards alumni Rachel Brosnahan
took home the globe for Best Actress for
a comedy thanks to her hilarious the
marvelous comedy series of course
celebrated tonight as well and there
were more to the winners James Franco
took home the globe yeah yeah I'm so
happy to hear that kind of you gotta get
up you gotta go onstage yeah I wanted a
reaction to that full speech oh yeah my
favorite female performance of the year
favorite performance of the year awesome
he was great in it too
it was Lady Bird and even though Greta
was completely snubbed when it came to a
Best Director nomination yeah she got
Ben Affleck Lady Bird star and Lady Bird
herself Saoirse Ronan also won Best
Performance by an actress good for her
and like any good daughter soutien eager
to give her mom a shout out right at the
top of her speech like my mom's on
FaceTime over there and someone's phone
right now so
I'm not a notable when I went to the
ever hilarious hi Tanya hell yeah
rightfully so and TV shows being honored
tonight so now that we've the winners I
want to know what you guys thought of
the shows and the movies that were
celebrated tonight which one surprised
you the most and which speech was your
favorite from the night let me know in
the comments section below now for that
be sure to hit that subscribe button for
more our show coverage thanks for
hanging out with me here on newsfeed out
of your girl Erin Robinson and I'll see
you next time click to the lab to see
the most empowering quotes from the
Golden Globes red carpet and to the
right to see the best dressed
celebrities from the show that's what I
want to see nice well thanks for
providing that clever because yeah the
only I knew about was James Franco
there's some winds here that I'm really
happy about big little lies like they
swept it man they slept at all their
ladies and Alexander Skarsgard and it
won best limited series as well and that
showed rightfully so I loved loved that
show it was it was gripping and intense
provocative and I was hooked from
beginning to end I'm really bummed
they're doing another season I wish they
weren't but oh hell what are you gonna
do when you're this popular right oh
yeah I remember when that show came out
that was everybody was watching that
yeah I still haven't seen it yet but I
remember when it was out cuz that was
the only show on anybody's lips for me
for at least a month and not that it's
100% about like sexual assault alone but
it is a show that is fairly relevant for
the time that were in and with Reese
Witherspoon making her speech earlier
during the meet to movement and them
talking about it again during her Golden
Globe speech I haven't watched it but
talking about it again just seems in the
right place the right format I suspect a
lot of people probably talked about
everything that's been go
the sexual harassment yeah I heard there
was a ton yeah
but a trumpets that even McGregor you
should have won two Golden Globes I know
yeah one way to people what you got to
do man that's the right way to do it's
unfair I want to catch Serling K Brown
speech I think we should do some
reactions to few of these species
speeches because certainly Kate brown
speech looked great okay yeah I heard a
lot about the Oprah Cicely deMille Award
yeah and I have no idea what you said
but everyone's like it's so moving
yeah well I'm good for is these two
winning winning actor for comedy right
yeah I think he's the first Asian
American actor to to win I don't really
agree necessarily that show belongs in
the Comedy category cuz it's a lot
especially in like the second season
it's a lot more of a dramedy I guess or
drama with humor in it but he's terrific
and especially as the nucleus of that
show I'm super psyched that you want
good for Aziz man James Franco winning
though Ranko was the one that I was
really happy to hear about like that's
the only one I heard about I was so
happy when I heard that I gotta watch
that speech I got I got a check that's
feature I'm for sure because to know
that Tommy was on stage with him just
sounds hilarious
yeah dude tommy was oh god got to be on
the Golden Globes stage and if that
movie gets nominated for an Oscar he
might be on the Academy yeah Awards
stage it's monumental where James
Franco's done man I mean you can look at
the man and be like yes great before ya
to be able to take one of the worst
performances in film history and then
make a great like character study
performance out of it through James
Franco's art beautiful most like strange
and mysterious just figures in modern
cinema Frances McDormand to me is wholly
one that I'm really happy about because
I've wanted her I've been wanting her to
win she is my favorite I think my
favorite performance of the year is
probably her actually and Sam Rockwell
rightfully so for three billboards as
well because that is one fantastic
performance like that's a hard art nail
and he totally got it down right you
guys haven't seen three billboards man
that's a hard-ass art to nail and for
Best Screenplay to it that's the biggest
takeaway I had
if I agree fully with it winning Best
Motion Picture I don't but I do think
that screenplay rightfully earned for
sure that dialogue and structure is well
done I mean that's some of the stuff I
always appreciate the most in a Martin
McDonagh joint is like the actors are
always on a game and the writing is so
intricate and there's so much going on
and then yeah this is just like that I
mean this is like the perfect blend of a
play and a film to me seriously yeah I'd
like definitely props for the Screenplay
award I do think it's weird somebody
pointed out that if ladybird won for
both Best Actress and Best Picture it is
weird that Greta Gerwig just didn't get
nominated for that hey man happen with
Ben Affleck with Argo and the Oscars and
he didn't get nominated for Best
Director but that won Best Picture
yes but if it's your lead and if it's
like your title character I'm a little
bit like guys yeah that's awkward I
think the same thing happened with walk
the wine but being Reese Witherspoon won
for that Joaquin Phoenix was nominated
and was nominated for Best Picture
but Jameis mangle wasn't nominated it
just happens sometimes I don't know why
they decide to do things like that but
whatever I Tonya and Lady burger two
movies I'm going to try to check out
this week I've been doing a lot of
awards season movies catch up lately
watch three billboards last week big
stick shape of water shape a water Gamal
del Toro winning Best Director rightful
the earth man yeah that I fully earned a
movie that only he could have made the
way he could have made it you know and
is so composed and so him yeah perfectly
relevant to the time that we live in
yeah Gary Oldman winning for darkest
hour is not exactly 100% surprise but it
does make the Oscars more intriguing now
because Danny day-lewis want to be
looking at of course yeah last movies
down they Lewis but if Gary Oldman beat
him out at the Golden Globes you're like
ooh Daniel day-lewis lose to his last
performance not that he cares he's
already had three Oscars so well yeah
see half my brain goes there I'm like he
doesn't need any more Oscars and the
other half goes maybe they're just gonna
you know consolation prize the other
person and then Oscar him up later
I like how Gary Oldman's when McGann
recognized a lot more lately in terms of
the awards because for the longest time
he was at underrated actor where
everyone's like how has he not gone the
nomination oh my god how is he
of all people yeah they're like so
method and such great character
performances I'm really happy that he
was able to win the Golden Globe at
least for this oh yeah and it seems like
that role was a pretty heavy undertaking
and involved a lot of like embodying
yeah yeah of course might check out a
few speeches I don't know the Golden
Gloves are it's like I like reading the
winner recaps but I don't really care to
watch the ceremony most of the time to
be honest so it's fun this is fine for
me is cool for certain people that I
least performances I know it's like
everything one that one other than three
billboard I could see why three
billboards one but I don't consider it
my personal favorite movie of the year
even in my top five it winning doesn't
bother me everything else that one that
I've seen I'm like yeah I can I can see
why that one because those are great I
try to catch the Lady Bird this week and
I try to catch maybe darkest hour as
well got a lot of few films to catch up
on cuz I wanna do an Oscar prediction
list like in Rachael Cushing on the
channel for that anyway guys thanks for
tuning in you guys can subscribe to the
real rejects please click that
notification bell to get notified
anytime one of our videos the SOB keep a
lookout for any further reactions
through these speeches be watched later
also make sure to become a patron oject
today it's like a second youtube channel
much more personal more customized
videos and got like way over at least
over a hundred 150 videos over so far so
go check it out